ha sido un momento muy emocionante
estamos en este momento en el Palacio
del plan alto donde hay muchos invitados
y en el momento en que Lula ha subido la
rampa hemos visto a muchas personas y
orando emocionadas todo el país se
preguntaba cómo iba a ser la entrega de
la Banda presidencial porque ya el
bolsonaro se ha marchado del país hace
dos días precisamente para no cumplir
con este protocolo finalmente
el equipo de la presidencia ha decidido
que fuese el propio pueblo que entregase
la banda presidencial a Lula y ha sido
un momento para muchas personas que
estaban aquí definido como memorable ha
habido digamos un pool de personas el
casi que reunir un líder indígena muy
reconocido y muy respetado nacional e
internacionalmente había un niño con
discapacitado una cocinera una
recicladora también un obrero
metalúrgico ha sido una entrega digamos
coral hecha por muchas personas y ha
llamado la atención la esperada
presencia de resistencia el perrito que
la esposa de Lula adoptó precisamente
cuando Lula estaba en la cárcel en
curitiba 580 días fueron en los que
todos los días sus seguidores les
deseaban Buenos días y buenas noches
esta perrita
apareció en este campamento fue la
mascota luego cuando se quedó digamos
enferma
decidió adoptarla entonces hoy la
presencia de este perro no ha sido
baladí era para recordar la resistencia
de Lula durante sus largos
de cárcel sobre su discurso él ha
hablado de muchas cosas durante
el su discurso pero le hemos visto
especialmente emocionado incluso
llorando cuando ha hablado del hambre y
de la desigualdad ha dedicado mucho
tiempo a esto ha recordado todo lo que
hizo en los primeros dos gobiernos y
luego lo que ha vuelto a recordar es que
va a tener que recomenzar de cero o casi
porque ha definido los últimos dos
gobiernos el de temer de dos años y el
de bolsonaro como gobiernos de
destrucción también ha prometido que va
a gobernar para todo el mundo que se
acabó el odio y ha hablado también que
quiere poner fin a la discriminación
racial y también al aislamiento
internacional que ha padecido Brasil en
los últimos años
Valeria